let me show you how compositing fog is
done right in most cases people change
the fog layer mode to screen and voila
you've got fog over your footage but the
fog lightened up the scene and that's
not accurate fog so the right way to
composite fog is super simple keep the
fog layer mode set to normal and go to
the effect shift channels change take
Alpha from alpha to luminance this
effect will make all the black values
transparent now one more step select the
effect generate fill pick a color from
the footage to match the fog to and
there you go the fog is composited in
the scene and it looks much more
realistic
foreign